I saw valiance of possible futures
billions of deaths I can't stop what's
coming for just right out of time
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
the best possible news
we finally have confirmed Tom Welling
Superman Smallville crossover coming to
crisis on Infinite Earths the flash
arrow all the other DC TV shows this
year so we'll break it down they talked
a little bit about what his storyline is
going to be and it will confirm some of
the theories that you guys have had
about what's been going on with Tom
Welling Superman since his show ended
we're doing a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best
Smallville's Superman theory for crisis
on the video if you're not sure what's
going on you just saw the news or you
just spoke up late last night what
happened is is Marc Guggenheim you used
to be the showrunner on arrow but who's
still kind of managing things from an
executive producer level and sort of
overseeing their crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover tweeted that they would
have huge news to reveal tomorrow
earlier this morning they then confirmed
that that news was that Tom Welling had
agreed to come back for a crisis on
Infinite Earths so of course people are
like what's going on is he gonna be
Superman is he gonna be Clark Kent what
are they gonna do with the other
Smallville characters or are they
finally canonizing the events of the
Smallville TV show - the arrow burst
because technically any time an actor
playing their character from another
show appears in the air overs it means
that they're trying to canonize that
show like John Wesley's ships 90s
version of Barry Allen flash all it
takes for them to canonize the show is
for that character to appear as their
character from the original show they
don't have to have any special storyline
or anything like that all they have to
do is walk in and say I'm Smallville
Superman from another earth it is their
way of explaining the larger DC universe
because in the arrowverse there was this
whole big thing about them only having
fifty three versions of earth because it
was a new 52 easter-egg 52 earths couple
of years ago they introduced earth X
that was the 53rd earth but if you've
been reading comics for a long time it's
called crisis on Infinite Earths for a
reason there should be infinite numbers
of Earth's in the multiverse they use
the John Wesley Shipp Barry Allen flash
during last year's crossover to correct
that oversight or at least expand the
universe whether or not they originally
intended on doing an infinite number of
Earth's all it took was them just saying
earth 90 in automatically there were
more than 53 earths so we don't know
what the
a nation of his earth on Smallville is
going to be because we've already been
to the Tyler hoechlin Supergirl version
of Smallville which is on earth 38 but
the way they explain it is they're going
to introduce him and explain what's
happened to his version of Superman ten
years after the end of that show now it
hasn't been a full ten years in real
life because the show ended in 2011 so
we're still a couple years away from
that
they're gonna bend time and space a
little bit ten years is just a nice
solid benchmark he's put on a lot of
city miles he's been Superman that whole
time it's not gonna be some super duper
depressing everything went to [ __ ]
storyline but the crazy thing about his
Superman is that he's just a little bit
younger than the Brandon Ralph version
of Superman who's playing Kingdom comes
Superman although he's playing his
Superman from Superman Returns so now we
have a full-on reign of the Superman
going on within crisis on Infinite
Earths there's so many different
versions of that Superman character we
know way more about what's going on with
the Tyler hoechlin Superman he's been
adamant that they're not developing a
Superman spin-off TV show with just his
character I think the twist is is
they're actually trying to do a super
boy style TV show where he's raising his
baby that he had with his version of
Lois Lane that they teased in last
year's crossover they went off to Argo
city to have that baby now they're
coming back for the crossover so they're
gonna have to explain what happened with
that young Superboy baby that they just
had but if you're big Smallville fan
like me then you actually know that they
did smallville season 11 in the comics
continuing his story showing what he did
in his first years as Superman because
the show ended just as he embraced his
identity as Superman put the costume on
so you just left to wonder what his time
his actual Superman was going to be like
but they dealt with it in the comics
they did a version of Justice League
they introduced a version of Wonder
Woman in that continuity all within sort
of the style in the tone of the
Smallville TV show because all the
heroes in their version of Justice
League looked a little bit different
from traditional comic-book Justice
League
all right let's do it
[Music]
so all that stuff happened in the last
ten years all that stuff is gonna be
canon they will have had their version
of Justice League they'll explain what
happened with that and what he's been
doing this whole time when he shows up
they didn't say exactly which episode
he'd debut in because remember it's five
episodes it's gonna be Supergirl on
Sunday night then Batwoman right after
that then the flash episode then the
arrow episode then the legends of
tomorrow episode but the arrow episode
in the legends episode won't air till
January they're only gonna air the first
three episodes then they go on break
then the second half airs when we come
back in January early prediction he's
going to debut during the first half of
the crossover they're not gonna make you
wait till January to see Tom Welling
Superman come back into the arrow first
they really really want everybody to
watch this crossover so adding Tom
Welling Superman is a really easy
slam-dunk way to get a lot of older
viewers to come back who are big fans of
the Smallville TV show and have sort of
left the newer shows as they gone on in
seasons Tom Welling himself and Stephen
Amell had been messing with fans about
him coming on the show for a long time
now Stephens started taking pictures
with him at conventions telling stories
about them reminiscing about being the
leading men in DC TV shows because
there's a lot of things that they share
in common even though Smallville
predates the modern DC TV universe by a
longtime if you go to a lot of
conventions - Tom Welling and Michael
Rosenbaum do a lot of appearances
together
he's also been asked if his version of
Lex Luthor is coming back to the DC TV
universe so you can bet that if Tom
Welling is coming back that Michael
Rosenbaum is also probably coming back -
but even just a little while ago at some
convention appearances when people were
asking because we're getting really
close to them actually filming the
crossover episodes this is the monitor
sitting on the set of one of the
episodes getting ready to film his
scenes he's full-on reading a crisis on
Infinite Earths comic book just teasing
fans he's not reading it because it's
part of the script or anything like that
he's just reading it to tease the fans
like oh look at what we're doing right
now we're totally doing the crossover
episodes just a little while ago Tom
Welling and Michael Rosenbaum said that
they had not been contacted about being
in the crossover which we knew was not
true because even earlier back at Comic
Con Marc Guggenheim who's the person
that's been announcing all this stuff
said that they've been in constant
contact with all the Smallville
actors agents trying to find a way to
get them to come back now when they say
Smallville actors I know a lot of you
are like wait what about Green Arrow
from Smallville because Justin Hartley
was taking pictures with Stephen Amell
at a convention a little while ago -
they're totally on good terms Justin
Hartley said he would totally be willing
to come back they even put an Easter Egg
for his version of Green Arrow in last
year's crossover in all the dead bodies
he was wearing the Smallville green
arrow costume so this is a big question
if they would actually get Justin
Hartley but because he's on a really
popular NBC network show it's a little
bit harder to get him right now
separately Lana Lang from that TV show
also said that she would love to come
back and she's still in relatively good
standing in the public eye there's no
scandals that she's involved in unlike
some other Smallville actors so it's a
little bit easier to get some of the
others to come back this is a picture
that the three of them took at a
convention a little while ago I have a
feeling that in a little while he'll
announce that she's coming back and
Michael Rosenbaum selects Luther is
coming back here's the thing about his
Lex Luthor though is because the main
version of Lex Luthor and the DC TV
InterVarsity end of last season of
Supergirl but then totally respawned by
the monitor because he had some purpose
to serve during the crossover that
version of Lex Luthor will probably play
a bigger role than the Michael Rosenbaum
version of Lex Luthor but I have a
feeling that however small or big their
parts are they'll still be very very
important to the story they haven't said
a whole lot more about what's going on
with Batman during the crossover the one
from the Batgirl TV show is still
missing off in the wild somewhere I like
to think that based on the Easter eggs
and the fact that that show takes place
in a place that looks a lot like The
Dark Knight because they filmed a lot of
those scenes in Chicago where they
filmed the Dark Knight trilogy is that
that version of Batman is actually the
Christian Bale version so he wouldn't
show up because there's no way the
Christian Bale is gonna come on the TV
shows but we are getting the Kevin
Conroy older Batman from Batman Beyond
Batman the Animated Series but they
haven't said a lot about what his role
is going to be or the Burt Ward
Robin who's going to be guest starring
from the 1966 Batman TV show but because
Brandon Ralph is actually going to be
leaving the DC TV universe he plays Ray
Palmer on legends of tomorrow but he's
going to be Kingdom comes Superman
during the crossover he's actually
leaving the DC TV shows after
this next season of legends of tomorrow
so what they'll probably do is give him
a really huge part they might wind up
sacrificing him as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all the videos when I post them
leave all your video requests in the
comments below we also got our first
look at Nightwing on Titans so I might
do a video for that later today there's
also some new spider-man sinister 6 and
venom videos that I'm working on so I'll
try to get that stuff out as fast as
possible there's just a lot of really
cool big news that just dropped this
week I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post that new DC video click here for
all my other flash season 6 trailer
videos and click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty's season 4 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight